[Musique]
pour le trophée de la meilleure pub
klein
jean michel maire
mais c'est parce que je suis désolé je
crois qu'elle parle d'elle moi je
travaille ici je travaille beaucoup
j'avais oui ça se verra quand géraldine
maillet aventure exceptionnelle c'est
pas du tout un livre politique
d'accord c'est le destin d'un homme qui
avait rien pour être président qui va
devenir président comme vous vous n'avez
rien pour être animateur et vous êtes
venus
jean luc lemoine
un gâteau prou là on a un gros dossier
sur elle selon vous dire et photo de toi
billets maxime du nid
comme si vous étiez vous éprouvez était
son frère de parti c'est ben ammar et
monsieur brown tizi on assisterait sont
attachés à la croissance
[Applaudissements]
et jean luc lemoine
alors isabelle alors moi pour le coup
évidemment que le temps passe et que
quand vous n'êtes pas l'avant en faisant
un récit d'ailleurs qu'on 82 où j'étais
la seule à le défendre
d'accord moi j'ai avalé des visions
c'est très efficace avec les chérir la
chronique apple améliore pas de gêne à
l'avenir sur un gars tu regardes gagnant
sur luc lemoine
gadjo deuxième trophée
[Applaudissements]